well look who it is it's your old uncle
Rick on the decks and now I'm taking
over this whole creep reason hey Rick
what are you doing in here Morty check
this out
yeah who cares
[Music]
so first can you give us a hint on what
to extract in season four and describe
any characters or voice actors that
you're gonna have on yes Wendy John
Lithgow pasts I know we tried to get him
you know yeah yeah Paul Giamatti why not
no no he didn't pass he actually said
yes and you know what god bless you Paul
Giamatti you're a hero
an angel no sorry good no III probably
are not allowed to say any of these
things I actually realizing right now
I'm recording him tomorrow okay what was
the question on any characters or
there's gonna be three robots Oh Rick is
gonna learn a very valuable lesson and
pay a heavy price and Morty - yeah like
the characters are going to generally
want the thing and then cross the
threshold in the journey to get at new
situations so they pay a heavy price and
achieve the things that they didn't know
they wanted and they're gonna be oh yeah
that's right that's right go to a
commercial then come back and go across
a return threshold where they you know
burst through this sincere answer is
yeah it's it's it's it's a dream come
true
this little baby basic-cable midnight
block and and then achieved bliss and
like a beat people know the show yeah
it's crazy I guess I the one thing
that's a bummer is that like when the
a-listers like it's half empty yeah it
is people that you always admired you're
like oh my god Susan Sarandon like she
knows the show but then they always
follow it up with pants my kid my kid
likes the show
I do have a question for you you did the
video with PewDiePie yes how was that
what was that like we honestly honestly
got true this we were oh god I almost oh
I almost no nothing I caught myself I
can't really tell you the true story of
how that happened but I will say that I
was hanging out with Ilan and then he
said will you do the this thing with me
and I was like yeah and then I don't
know what it was at first and I was like
oh this is the thing the PewDiePie thing
and I yeah that's it but that's that's
the truth the meme review yes and dan
knows where I was where I where I was
where I were we were just hanging out
with you and Wes for no reason I had car
trouble welcome back everyone its
charlie we have a brand new Rick and
Morty season four teaser to break down
in an interview with Dan and Justin
about what's going on during season 4
isn't it surprising that they're using
so much overt evil Morty to promote the
season 4 episodes so we'll break it all
down there's giveaway stuff I'm doing
I'll explain at the end of the video but
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the
easter-egg videos of course I'll be
doing Rick and Morty episode videos just
like I did for season 3 and I'll talk
about the release date at the end of the
video - but you're starting with the
footage rick hijacks the promo using his
computer notice he's drinking pure
alcohol yer totally nice day drinker his
special helmet that he's been building
in a box in the garage is now in the
background the one that everyone thinks
that he's gonna use to end himself with
a special fluid there's also a bunch of
pictures on the wall of his past
adventures
there's dr. xenon bloom from anatomy
Park still salty about Pirates of the
pancreas there's a picture of zip Zam
floorp who's supposed to be sort of his
con from Wrath of Khan supposedly he's
still alive down in the Microverse Dan
and Justin have joked about bringing him
back but because time moves so much
faster for them at that level if they
ever did bring him back they'd have to
find a way to explain how he
counteracted the flow of time down there
there's a picture of a bird off link ler
may he rest in peace this amorphous blob
creature seems like it's one of the
people from c-137 Cronenberg earth more
meeseeks I think they're actually some
meeseeks Easter eggs that they're
including in the new season four
episodes but I
how big the meeseeks themselves are
going to be during season four then
there's a whole bunch of different
versions of Rick's consuming Morty's a
very apt metaphor for their relationship
in the series with a big evil Morty
twist at the end they started in a
cyberspace Tron looking reality then
they turn into what looks like
single-celled organisms with the Rick
one consuming the Morty one then under C
which seems like a reference to the Rick
lantus mix-up where Morty got some hot
mermaid love bottom-feeding morty fish
that seems like a pretty harsh burn on
morty calling him a bottom-feeder a rick
shark swimming through more morty
jellyfish consuming one of them another
burn on morty then a rick hippo on the
African plains getting ready to consume
a morty bird then rick godzilla
destroying a city with his atomic breath
getting ready to fight Mothra morty then
a more tea space probe trying to escape
a rick meteorite that's crashing into
the planet they continue to evolve out
as you then go to a morty planet being
consumed by a black hole rick pretty
dark interpretation of their
relationship with morty metaphorically
being eaten alive by rick if he doesn't
assert himself and find a way to break
free of his orbit quote-unquote then
surprise twist God level evil Morty
crushing both of their celestial bodies
as if he somehow exists on a level
beyond both of them but I think the
interpretation here is that evil Morty
within the context of the series itself
isn't meant to be a god the beauty of
the character I think just based on the
pitch that they told us so far which
could change down the road is that he's
meant to be another morty from the
central finite curve on the evil end of
the spectrum just like evil rick
explained the spectrum to c-137 rick
like you're not that different from me
and it's not that he's the most evil
version of morty he's probably not even
the smartest because if there's at all
Morty Rick then there's probably a short
Rick version of Morty who's super-smart
out there
the theory is as the evil Morty is
supposed to be a morty who was just in
the right place at the right time came
to a grand realization about his purpose
in all this in the central finite curve
and went about making his vision a
reality with the same stubborn
determination that a Rick would he just
a completely Unchained version of Morty
Oh Morty that's gotten too high on
himself jumped up his own butt too much
the way that Rick explained to him back
the original evil Morty episode in
season 1 but in theorizing that evil
Morty didn't start out is a particularly
special version of Morty it's a way of
metaphorically saying that our Morty
also has the potential to be just as
great or just as evil and accomplish all
these things if he wanted it bad enough
like almost any Morty is capable of
becoming evil Morty except maybe tall
Morty or maybe hammer Morty may he rest
in peace
but breaking down all the details from
that season 4 interview Paul Giamatti
gonna be one of the first guest stars
they announced I suppose he's gonna be
in one of the earlier episodes but it
might not be the very first episode Sam
Neill from the Jurassic Park movies is
going to guest star they didn't say what
he'd be doing because they already did a
Jurassic Park parody episode in anatomy
park so they might be using it for
something a little bit different Tycho
YTD obviously is playing the glooty
character from the comic-con trailer
that i already did a video for he's just
an alien that baits Jerry into creating
a tinder style ripoff dating app for him
that has terrible consequences it's just
meant to be a big send up of the idea
that Jerry has no self-control because
the alien literally has do not make this
app tattooed on his forehead
but Jerry does it anyway I also love
that in this footage in the background
you can see in Jerry's office he still
has a picture of the Titanic hung up
despite the fact that he was assaulted
by that woman on the Titanic theme park
ride I'm sure if they dig around this
office somewhere you'll find his special
coin collection maybe they'll have an
Easter Egg for that during the episode
Kathleen Turner is also gonna be a guest
star they didn't say what kind of
character she's playing and now
apparently based on this interview it
sounds like Elon Musk is also going to
be doing a guest spot because they spent
almost the whole last minute of that
interview trying to not tell Anne Elon
Musk's story then backtracking a lot
like we totally just didn't say that we
were recording Elon Musk at his office
for some reason and that's also where he
explains the pewdiepie meme review video
and how justin roiland wound up doing
that video the way Justin and Dan became
friends with Elon Musk is that during
season three or before season three Elon
Musk's kids were huge Rick and Morty
fans and they wouldn't shut up about it
so he started tweeting about it so of
course Dan and Justin started tweeting
back at him and then that's when they
connected they went and hung out with
him at Tesla and then obviously it
sounds like they arranged for him to do
it
spot during season four maybe he'll wind
up being another zebes and floor type
character that winds up butting heads
with Rick just another really smart
person that Rick has a huge disagreement
with as for the season four release date
they've only said November but right now
they've scheduled again deed Tartakovsky
x' primal for early october that's gonna
finish airing October 11th so they might
use that to promote Rick and Morty
season for the play drop a trailer
sometime during that too meaning they
could wind up dropping Rick and Morty as
early as the beginning of November but
I'm expecting somewhere around the
middle and because it's gonna be ten
episodes for season four it's gonna
overlap with Christmas and New Year's no
matter what so it's not totally clear if
they're gonna do five episodes then go
on break and hear the rest of the five
or if they'll just plow right through
the holidays and not take a break
between episodes the really good news
about season five also is that they're
into production on season five already
meaning that the break between season
four and season five will be really
really small compared to the delays that
have happened in the past and the same
for future seasons after that but the
way Dan Harmon is talking about it it
might continue to be ten episodes per
season but they did work out a special
production deal with Adult Swim in their
new contracts that allow them to deliver
more episodes per season if they get
ahead of schedule so they could always
drop 12 episodes in season 5 or 14
episodes a lot of that's just up to
Adult Swim Dan Harmon just said that
they would deliver as many episodes as
quickly as possible an Adult Swim would
be the ones to decide how they divvy
those episodes up between seasons I'll
keep doing Rick and Morty bonus videos
as we get closer to the premiere if you
have a video that you want to request
just post it in the comments below and
there is a Rick and Morty merch giveaway
that I'll do in my Rick and Morty videos
all you have to do to enter that is be
subscriber and leave your best season
for Theory on the video I'll name a
winner when I post my next Rick and
Morty video click here for my breakdown
of that comic-con trailer and click here
for all my Rick and Morty season 3
Easter egg videos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]